during that time what was some of the
best advice aside from that line in taxi
that's excellent I love the show and
what was some of the worst advice he got
you not to tell you names but like what
were some things that were just so
cliche and it's just like no this is
like a power speech that's and then some
stuff that was like wow that's really
interesting that like in that time frame
when that sort of like I mean I want to
say it's maybe more of a dip it sounds
like it yeah came out of it yeah
definitely a dip uh some people are full
of well-intentioned advice and it just
is like now that's not gonna work but
then others have interesting what you
know what the best piece of advice I got
during that time was from my girlfriend
at the time and she said you should just
write a movie and then sell it to a
studio and then you can find out how it
all really works and that's why I wrote
my first script and that was a really
great piece of advice um and I guess
because of me thinking of it that simply
I was able to sell my first grass maybe
that's why I don't know I mean it's not
it's obviously not that easy but in my
head it was and so I wrote this thing
and we got it out and done that was
probably the best piece worst piece
well no no I mean there were there there
they were bad begging said to me weren't
necessarily advice like nobody ever said
you know go home kid you bother me
but I don't know if I got a piece of bad
advice but I did get that I did get that
advice and I decided to write and we
said we sold that script to Columbia
from the time that she told you that how
did how much time went by when you
started writing that script next day
next day wow this is before Starbucks
for now yeah this is around the world
exists I'm sorry
there probably was Starbucks but I don't
drink coffee oh you know okay I can't
I'm one of those weirdos it doesn't so
so so you where did you start writing
the script cuz there I had a friend who
was an aspiring writer and he had final
draft so I went to him and I said hey
man I wanna write a script and he was
like you wanna what I said just give me
the final draft show me how it worked
he's like that's not how final drive
works let's dude whatever just you know
I just just show me how it works
so he taught me how I work he's like you
just do that and hit the tab key and
write the things like all right it's why
you're gonna write uh-huh someone write
script I'm writing script we didn't have
an idea not it's like floating around
now no it's like I'm just gonna write
one I read them all my life can't be
that hard
hard but I figured just write a script
to start like what am i doing I'm
sitting here and staring at a phone it
doesn't rain you know phone's not going
anywhere I'm not going anywhere I could
be sitting here a year from now and me
and my phone can be hanging out together
or I could be sitting here here from now
me and my phone could be hanging out
with a script that I wrote so I started
writing and then I was like I just want
to figure out something that work and at
the time it was like he had all these uh
like it was like the team stuff was hot
so this is like post screen this is like
Cruel Intentions
and you know I know what you did last
summer when the lights went off in
Georgia or whatever so I was like
alright so they're making this stuff and
everything was in high school so I was
like okay I'll put something in college
all right what's a story they all seem
to be horrors and thrillers okay oh yeah
so I started looking at films that were
really really popular like in the 80s
take that story that basic idea set it
in college now I got a thing that's a
proven track record that works but then
I got this other thing and it's new when
it's fresh and it's different and that
became the first script that became I
would die for you it's about a guy going
the Santa Barbara UC Santa Barbara and
had a girlfriend and life was good and
buddy his in his hometown was getting
married so he goes back to his home town
for the wedding
without his girlfriend because she was
off doing whatever and he runs into his
ex-girlfriend from high school and she
and he end up
you know and he leaves he says you know
it's a mistake whatever it's good to see
you goes back to his life and UC Santa
Barbara turns around
there's the ex-girlfriend hey how are
you what's up sis your girlfriend oh my
god she's so great
now the girlfriend loves the
ex-girlfriend and he's in hell and that
became that became I would die for you
and Colombia brought that up we had a
good time with it it's fun how long did
it take you to write it hate this
question no it's good it's good it's
good uh three weeks three weeks
Wow yeah how many drafts did you do
before I sold it
three maybe four what will be it wasn't
it was a lot and into a lot of drafts
are you working as an actor at this time
you have an odd job no no no I'm I'm
I've now sort of moved into the whole
like filmmaking scenario so a buddy of
mine named James Lang tine got together
and we created a production company and
we were working on films that I write
and direct and star in and we shot our
first one this is now back in April and
now we're working on our second thriller
coming out in October and we've got
plans for the third film want to shoot
next spring so yeah that's that's that's
where I'm at now at that time though
like so how did you get access to pitch
Columbia oh oh oh yeah okay sorry
No then yes I was still sort of making a
living as an actor you know and you know
you hired there by that time I had done
murder one and in YPD blue so they were
like really healthy residuals floating
around like a residual from murder one
one year night of years like one day I
just went as a residual was like $15,000
from her tomorrow
I bought a car it was great so that was
where that was at that time
and I had a friend who was comedian and
he had a buddy who was a manager a
literary manager and I called my
comedian friend up his names are mad
I met him ed and he says hey man I said
I got the script man I'm think it's
really good I want to sell it he's like
you should call Brian dude Brian's a
manager now you call him up give me your
script see what you can do I was like
okay so I sent it to Brian and Brian was
like so what you want to do is like dude
I don't care like I don't care if they
want to turn into pigs on the moon
it'll be pigs on the moon I don't care I
just want to sell things so I won't find
out how it works
because nobody will tell me how it works
this whole thing so I could find out how
everything works he's like all right
cool
so he sat he read it came some notes
went back and forth through the notes
and so then once he was happy with it he
decided to do like a soft what do they
call it not pitch when the agents and
managers they send it out I don't know
soft send out I don't know that they
have a name for it I can't remember but
he sent it out to a few people as
opposed to like a blanket thing you know
because usually you know you do go wide
with it you send it out to all the
studios and all the production companies
and you see who bites so he's like I'm
gonna send out two people I know first
see what they think
see how it plays and then we'll go
bigger I was like all right cool
so at the time there was a production
company cannot remember the name of
production company I had a deal at
Warner Brothers and the executive at the
production company was chanting Dungey
and Channing is actually now I believe
she's the head of drama at ABC now but
she read it and she was like this is
good I like this I want to go out with
it and she did the same thing Brian did
she was like I'm not gonna go why I'm
just gonna guy guy friend let's see how
a place so she sent it to a woman named
Carrie Richman and Carrie was an exec
you
at Columbia at Sony so she took it to
carry and carry ready and carry was like
I like it was good
has anybody else seen it she's like no
no I seen it not yet tell you what we're
gonna make a pre-emptive thing we'll
make an option and let's do it and we
did it and that's how the first one
happened see I didn't want to be vague
about it that's how it actually happens
thank you for the detail that's how it
actually happened so it wasn't like you
know there wasn't like a big sort of
where they call it dos machina it wasn't
like a big thing that just sort of like
landed you know CA didn't just show up
and go oh that didn't happen it was a
little manager and he knew some folks
though they knew some folks and
everybody loved the script it all came
back to me like the script and as I've
continued I've realized it all comes
down to that all comes down to the words
on these pieces of paper we dig those so
let's see what we can do that's what's
always come down to in my experience so
you